[Music]
football
tell me about that as long as i have a
ball in my hands
i feel a lot
kind of like how i feel right now
i'm staying there i got work today work
the nfl is not going to draft some dude
from the 1a school in iowa
there were other offers i called every
team in the nfl no one's interested
[Music]
can i get one of your applications i
promised that i would take care of you
and the kids
so that is exactly what i'm gonna do
this is your dream to give up on it
[Applause]
[Music]
kurt warner who got the whole package
kid
the world just needs more time to see it
he came up with this whole arena concept
arena football
it's like a circus
people love the circus i like the
surface
you pay me for touchdown i also pay you
to win that's gonna be fine
hey kurt we've been trying to reach you
i'm sorry who are you i'm with the rams
this guy's old slow is molasses he's
beneath the standards of this franchise
that's what people said about me when i
came here
all those years
gave me something others
didn't have
me ready for this moment
third warner out of the arena league
it's one of those stories that's too
good for the movie the perfect guy here
he was bagging groceries five years ago
go out there and you show the world what
i've known all along
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my time i know who i am and i
know why i'm
all
here
[Music]
you